alors piccolo bonsoir reçoit partie sais
quoi dans la vie
je me réserve bien entendu ça rend
service parce que quand j'entendais le
poisson c'est venu comme ça
ouais je donnais mes recettes les
recettes il ya toujours des herbes dans
les concepts et les gens il faisait le
tour de cendres venu on n'a rien trouvé
alors je me suis dit bon ben je faisais
encore leur jeu alors je commençais à
l'affiché des herbes et je faisais
cadeaux à mes clients et après j'ai
arrêté je dis maintenant je les vends et
il trouvera ses herbes et là le fenouil
il y en a un peu partout c'est pas les
autres je vais dans les affres de votre
province
ah bon je vais jusqu'au pont de kolda
lors je suis allé jusqu'à l'été dernier
parce que nous comme il ya vu la
sécheresse il ya eu des problèmes mais
j'en ramassais pas beaucoup parce que
s'il fait sec ça peut se parler on ya
même eu des endroits connus comme un
aventurier ouais ça s'appelle comment
c'est un métier reconnu ça ab je ne sais
pas s'il est reconnu mais en france
c'est une tolérance
il ya beaucoup de retraités hongrie 22
des aromates comme moi et qui payent pas
d'impôts moi ma femme forte et bien
entendu si le verbe pas misère à joindre
les deux bouts
et croyez-moi ça vient pas tout seul est
ce que quand je ramassais désherbe j'ai
des risques il ya deux ans j'ai pris
trop de pénalités
l année dernière je n'ai prévu non j'ai
pas été mon but j'ai eu de la chance
et puis j'ai été je suis comme les
abeilles mon pic des fois que c'est pas
mauvais mais quant à ben brik a été
piqué par une abeille est bien de faire
du 20 minutes j'avais les mains et pieds
en prix et on était comme une journée et
j'étais au logis du psg des ceintures à
feuillage je suis allé mollo docteur dr
april attention il va finir carrément
mâchonner le premier
métallisé et 10 mois mais vipère les
plus dangereux c'est l'église c'est ça
les crises une petite annie perreault
crise ça c'est plus dangereuse qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire si on se fait piquer
par une vipère des cantons se fait
piquer par un super première des jeunes
il faut pas s'affoler il faut pas se
voiler parce que je pourrais vous portez
le vaccin mais il faut pas s'y fier là
dessus parce qu'il faut qu'il soit
toujours dans un frigo et s'il a pris la
chaleur et je m'appuie là dessus je
crève alors il faut pas s'affoler
vous allez gentiment dans votre voiture
vous prenez votre voiture et vous allez
dans le village de l'eure le plus près
possible
on a d'ailleurs - copies coeur que le
monde surnommait nallo là on va faire
deux minutes vous êtes au cas où ces
morts là ça va droit au coeur
ah ouais et c'est vrai qu'il faut su
c'est un peu le venin non oui il y en a
beaucoup qui le disent ça c'est des
bureaux mais de temps en temps
pour laisser comme ça y est on y perd le
mot mort si vous cessez de vous faites
comme chez vous ça fait une réaction
encore ça vous active là pour être non
non non non non seulement voyez les
plantes comme ça il faut que je me dise
en face à des propriétés médicinales et
aromatiques soins oui oui ça c'est une
plante que c'était une hauteur de ce
qu'on veut nous fait nous autrement dit
si vous êtes ballon mears a voté un peu
passé et si vous allez l'adorer savoure
a fait passer les si vous êtes constipé
aussi en hongrie les deux extrêmes alors
on rigole séparé à leur égard ça fait
quoi robrig ans et l'origan du déficit
c'est un désinfectant de bronze
voyons ça c'est très très bon voyez vous
pour le bronze
il faut le prendre comme un brigand vous
faites des infusions voyez vous oui et
puis après vous avez là semble aussi que
c'est très bon ça c'est la sarriette
c'est très bon et ça tue les microbes
qu'on peut avoir d'un estomac que les
microbes ascension et metz à la
sarriette ont à peine sa loupe et
brident après le second bébé parce que
dans les paysages
il avait des milliers mais il faudra
dire le poivre des années se traduira
pour voir les photos de représailles
en français ça veut dire le poivre deux
ans et à l'origine de la série je mène
partout il y en a ça plus adapté et bien
entendu car on ne pouvait plus marcher
un bourricot la 85 kg et le fait il a
fait un ou deux kilomètres un peu plus
peut plus marcher un peu la patte
alors il enrage ça il faut que ça pour
que ça se jouerait le cul oui ça bouge
pas mais ça tu es bon alors là en
trépignant marché alors que benoît
jacquot réserve alors voyez ça c'est
jean finalement qu'ils connaissaient
leur est remboursé par la sécurité
sociale des trucs mais justement
puisqu'on me parler de la seconde guerre
je vais vous apprendre alors voyez je
suis choquée qui a la moitié des
français et des françaises qui ne savent
pas ce que c'est le thème mais qu'il y à
quoi ça sert
qu'est ce que c'est le thème bien mettez
vous savez c'est bon pour le faire c'est
bon pour beaucoup de choses
eh bien figurez vous qu'à toi on est
malade si les gens savaient parce que là
je vais demander au ministre de
l'éducation de faire une heure de conte
botanique pour les jeunes qu'ils
étudient
ouais ok c'est pas possible ça et sur le
plan aphrodisiaques
abc est ce qu'on peut faire au 10e voilà
on fait des petits plateaux et ça c'est
formidable et jambes à deux c'est tout
et c'est un effet oui sûrement il ya 9
femmes qu'elles émanent acheter les
bijoux peut-être un jour a pris elle m'a
dit qu'elle a commencé à incendier si
l'as bram dix commandements du tout m
pour pouvoir les aphrodisiaques
j'ai pris ça pour mon mari qu'il était
très faiblard et tout comme vous l'avez
donné 10 rebonds le matin en me levant
je vous avais dit le petit alors je me
dis vous comprenez c'est un homme
sérieux maintenant que fait la cour à la
bonne
olala mais ça marche arabe je sais que
je pose est là est-ce que toi piccolo tu
t'en sers de son cocktail aphrodisiaques
ah non et pourquoi quand j'avais 20 ans
on n'a pas besoin je faisais l'amour une
fois ouais je faisais l'amour de fois je
m'endormais la tête sur ce match je
donnerai tout l'après-midi un mail de la
première fois ça me réveille
or il faut être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu